legalizar Las bajas temporales por
menstruación es una gran apuesta que
será observada por el mundo a la
expectativa de su efectividad Cuáles
serán en su opinión las consecuencias de
que las mujeres puedan acceder a ellas
tanto en el mercado laboral como en los
Derechos Humanos
la situación de salud en este caso una
menstruación incapacitante incapacitante
significa que no va a poder desarrollar
su trabajo Igualmente va a tener que
acceder a algún tipo de baja médica Lo
que pasa que lo que sucede es que
normalmente tendríamos que acudir al
médico y con otra excusa o con un motivo
que no sea este acceder a algún tipo de
baja Entonces yo entiendo que lo que se
está dando sobre todo es un
reconocimiento simbólico de que las
mujeres las personas menstruantes
podemos tener realidades menstruales que
implican dolores incapacitaciones
etcétera y que desde las instituciones
públicas se da cobertura a esta
situación Y en lugar de que esto pase en
una clandestinidad o que esto pase en
una situación de la que no tenemos
registro o que parece que nos tengamos
que esconder pues se le dé cobertura y
se le den reconocimiento y creo que esto
tiene que ver también con a nivel
simbólico como se exige a las mujeres y
a las personas que menstruamos que
trabajemos en condiciones a veces que no
tienen en cuenta los propios ciclos de
nuestros cuerpos Pero esto no significa
que ahora vaya a haber más ventajas que
antes porque las personas que ya las
necesitaban seguramente estaban
accediendo a ellas de forma más precaria
Marta una parte que fue legalmente
discutido o largamente discutido fue el
de los 16 años como edad para tomar la
decisión de abortar sin autorización de
los padres Lo mismo para la ley trans
Por qué se ha llegado la conclusión de
que lo más conveniente era rebajar la
edad mínima
yo creo que aquí hay una cuestión muy
importante en primer lugar en relación
al aborto está claro que si yo con 16
años Soy lo suficientemente madura y
adulta como para atraer al mundo a una
criatura y sacarla adelante con todo lo
que implica al menos las personas que
hemos sido madres o padres Yo creo que
por lo tanto también tengo la capacidad
de tomar una decisión tan importante
como de no tener esa criatura Por otra
parte y esto también tiene que ver a lo
mejor en el contexto de los 16 años y la
ley trans no todas las personas formamos
parte de familias donde a lo mejor se
acojan ciertas noticias o ciertas
diversidades de forma de la misma manera
o de forma acogedora no Entonces a lo
mejor una menor que está embarazada no
tiene un contexto propicio para poder
explicar que se ha quedado embarazada y
que quiere terminar con ese embarazo o
una persona que es trans o que o que es
rgtb a lo mejor comunicar esa noticia en
su domicilio en su familia le va a
implicar una serie de Consecuencias
negativas o no se va a aceptar esa
circunstancia con lo cual por lo tanto
yo es importante dar cobertura a que las
personas con 16 años podemos tener un
cierto grado de madurez y por ejemplo en
lo que decía no en embarazos si yo puedo
decidir ser madre y sacar delante una
criatura con todo lo que implica también
debo poder decidir no serlo en libertad
y de otro lado aunque los grupos
feministas celebran la mayoría de
cambios aprobados hoy algunas colectivas
rechazan la ley trans desde una postura
que no reconoce a las mujeres
transgénero porque estas divisiones
ideológicas y en qué aportan a la
discusión
yo creo que no que no aportan gran cosa
en el sentido de que obviamente puede
haber diversidad de opiniones pero no
puede haber diversidad de opinión donde
se niega la humanidad de colectivos Y
todavía más si son colectivos
minorizados y minoritarios discriminados
yo entiendo que debe partir del
desconocimiento las personas que tenemos
la suerte de compartir filas activistas
con compañeras trans en todo el espectro
sabemos que no son nuestras enemigas ni
que han venido a amenazar nuestros
derechos sino que son nuestras
compañeras y que avanzamos juntas y
avanzamos todas en un mundo más igual y
más justo para todas